difficile che oggi nuova challenge in
cui non dovremmo scegliere il bicchiere
sbagliato abbiamo già fatto speciale
secondi di salieri potito risparmiato
dove tenere stata una sbagliata devi
seguire ma non si era sbagliata del
scegliere quanto sbagliato e non mi
ricordo giusta strada
comunque abbiamo trovato questo gioco
ieri sono usciti sulla nutrizione molto
famoso gioco 66 prezzo in pratica
bisogna tirare la pallina nel bicchiere
mese.lo vecchi poi bene quello che si è
detto ingerirne del gioco vale lo
abbiamo trasformato cioè sembra una
palina perché ritiene dobbiamo mettere
questa sessione entro noi non vediamo
cosa stai dentro la fa tra l'altro
questa cosa ci sia dentro dobbiamo
metterla dentro il nostro specchio e poi
andremo ad attivare le slide con
qualsiasi cosa ci abita abbiamo ci sono
ingredienti fini e ingredienti
schifosissimi ingredienti bellini tv
degli schifosi ingredienti brutti quale
si ricorda abbiamo sei palline set
assiste non riusciamo a prenderlo stati
ome turno e poi tocca all'altro quindi
bene e alla fine del video come per
primi essere un vantaggio in cui potrete
portare subito ios
bello è quando recente vi chiede non
dovremmo guardare cosa c'è dentro finché
non rovesciamo quindi non possiamo
guardare costituì ad essa lo dobbiamo
non guardare e professare e potete demo
direttamente sotto il nostro specchio
come capitato studiano che si vieta
attrattivo non si resta così a sapere se
voi sono anticamente niente qui per le
facciate lasciate un bel live lines
vines volete vedere altri talenti
consigliate se l'è pure nei momenti non
so se siete accorti ma questi bicchieri
sono giganti
mettetevi comodi breve di go kart video
tutto schermo e mi capita di guardare il
bicchiere cosa chiedono
[Musica]
l'iter e quant'altro bene sono mentre
l'idea di toccare tutto non solo utile
da sotto con the dust of random sopra
perché era niente è cambiato che aveva
come dai
[Musica]
caffè doney a fallire
stranamente è intatta montaguto di odio
dal canto loro anche quando non avremo
mai collo ancora quindi aumentare sono
capitati i concetti come si chiamano
fishburne l'ipotesi delle classi di
plastica e il colorante giallo giallo
shirt sia un limone e funzionalmente se
chiudi un occhio umano
[Musica]
viviamo dai pali per qualche del v10
giornali tavolo per l'estate disastro
[Musica]
dai occuparla vissero un pochettino
meglio a questo gioco non possono così
difficile non guardare mai vedere
[Musica]
o no porca palline olga quindi passata
al 36 la colla buttarsi a icona e
colorante rosso che qualcosa vorrei
farti vedere che sono schiappe una
doppietta mentre dai ma attenzione ha
speculato premia un po teso secco al
tracollo mai questa cosa bianca nome in
genere c'è la sorpresa sotto che qui ero
sorpreso se il colorante sotto del
colorate bilico rosa rosa
ventura perché qui prendo la pallina che
esporti io non gioco vediamo piccola mi
è capitato col
il cane dopo vediamo che di aiuti nel
cuore avvenuto che uno strike di s mi
chiamo e allora ecco quali sono che mi è
capitato che bello il giallo fluo anche
se non è tantissimo però meglio di
niente è già tanto che ho beccato
qualcosa quindi questo è il mio time
finora mi spiace con il suo cuore
terreno tipi di opera di vitale ecco di
diminuire super stupendo guardaremo come
diventa mente pianto perché è pieno di
roma de rosa sono pure cosa sotto però
dei rossi verdi non abbiamo girato sera
tutto incollato al software avere una
gravità slime fragoroso mai fragala
vediamo
[Musica]
che fortuna è veramente bello giocare
meglio
spieghiamo è molto più difficili da un
po che se vediamo
ma allora non guardare tremila falsi e
[Musica]
cresciuto a è assurda
vai
[Musica]
la mia vita mia tutto ha portato bene
sarebbe però talmente belle di pietro a
destra invece qualcosa anch'io adesso
che bello che bello
no io non so come te io lo guardo allora
con la pallina prima bagnata o un brutto
presentimento che si divide mettiamo che
la cosa liquida allora è sicuramente
verde e liquido meschino
deve capitare
no so niente se guardate un po ne ho
beccato solo due di bicchieri e dovevo
bastare questo ma che cosa è un liquido
verde schifoso artista scelte facendo
separare la colla io spero strutti
diventerà un ciclo slime guarda il cloud
è naturale però di beccare un colorante
almeno perché vediamo il tuo come di
merita vediamo un po di tempo lori visto
che i colori che ci sono già e
bellissimo troppo bello è bellissimo
ok adesso il colore ha cambiato un
pochettino visto che come color romitino
meglio color salmone no questo è color
pesca mostrando ma sento ancora rosati
dovermi skouris chiara bene potete di
genere cui diventerà bellissimo
diventerà il range a380
manca pochissimo
[Musica]
dovevo intrappolati perché è proprio
curioso di vedere cosa ci sarà allora
non guardo con la faccia carina che
bagnata a finire che tutti i tifosi
questo doveva capitare a te quindi spero
che sia una cosa bene sono arrivato qui
vediamo molto grave che pedro
[Applauso]
waterslide nel senso che sono solo foto
non si arriverà mai
manca pochissimo assoluto in bicchieri
chi li perderà sì al primo corpo da
guardare ma guardare perché spagna 20
menti versa match che cos'è la bianca
[Applauso]
[Musica]
valida marina
allora io penso comunque di essere
quella messa peggio perché è solo non si
sa mai niente acqua dice colore uscito
prima verde che sica vediamo il tuma
cemento meno medica picchiato
l'ingrediente schifoso anche magari mia
gente ora l'impatto di qualcosa della
coca
io ragazzi una porta firewire uscirà
fuori
il dolore di la popolazione sembra un
impasto solo per una fragola che sarà un
uomo buono come diventa il tuo non volta
stimola un po pomodoro ma continuiamo il
mio non diventerà niente perso il nuovo
acqua
e difficilissimo dai ritornato a niente
ma esistono può accadere con colla o mio
dio ora spero che sia un colore decente
nero fantastico abbiamo bisogno di te mi
gioco il nero per i ragazzi di mia inter
si vuole online
la neo sono contenta k almeno c'è un po
di colla perché se non riusciva niente
sfida all'ultimo bicchiere impossibile
dai
6 platì aiuto in camera non si vede mai
parlato tutto più corriva famiglia si
sarebbero tutte le cose attaccate
artista capsulare multa che porterà
palline l'uomo ti sei profitto al voto
vediamo un po mischia che fortuna è
avuto con le palline
a parte che sarà grande disturbo qui tra
strati potrà arancione è stato
bellissimo il mio sacco stanato poi alla
farina
infatti attiva adesso vediamo riuscirà
forse tese un ciclo grigio cioè perché
grigio almeno ci sono un po di glitter
li vedete che erano della colla gialla
fluo per aprire il resto innanzitutto lo
slime sporchi
noi andiamo ad attivarli sperando che ci
riusciamo
e poi vi facciamo vedere potrete votare
stea video vitale stabili tonalità per
avere un gommone lo chiamò perché oggi
che ve l'ho guardata sentiamo il suo
allora questo lo slime gene gommone
secondo massimo ha fatto ne ho fatti di
meglio a livello di porting però sa pure
un po di suoni
tutti che bolle
ecco fa chiede abbastanza elastico bello
morbidone fatto partendo molto
spezzatino non troppi solo 26 toccare
come carini non ti piace e velo
bellissimo il cuore molto particolare il
collo di gommoni ok porcate adesso
allora il mio molto particolare perché
se non si così tanto liquido
sono rimasta sorpresa perché mi piace un
sacco la consistenza la mia uscita una
sorta di blitz vedete ma la consistenza
mi piace un sacco di booking che un
pezzo ed è super lucido vedete restate
su un alone di suo con lucido toccato
per il colore si farà alla fine non
abbiamo mai fatto un grigio chiaro
vedete quindi è originale ma guardo
quindi che morbido e rimasto chi
su berlusconi pochi la consistenza e
meglio la mia e piazze signor più bello
il proprio volto
chi vince quindi mi è uscito un cicli
grossi è tuo è uscito un gran rumore di
calci flptp per contesti materile quindi
ibiza editor vitale ma per uno vi è poi
fatto utilizzando particolari
si no io sono abbastanza super
allungarsi ma alla fine anche se puntata
sfigato solo così a casa la franchezza
che ve lo cito questi quindi votate con
nessun da giusto edizioni tosse vince
vitale e ora mi lascia un po quattro
case lines criticare per vedere le
nostre sociale sviluppi video video
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferisce